طيف اعاده احياء الاتفاق النوويه الايراني
يقلق تل ابيب التي تسابق الزمن لعرقله
ابرامه فالاخبار الرائجه داخل اسرائيل
تشير الى وجود توافق بين واشنطن وطهران قد
يدفع في اتجاه التوصل الى اتفاق النووي
هذا ما اكدته صحيفه يدعو تحرر نوت
الاسرائيليه والتي كشفت عن تزايد احتمال
التوصل الى اتفاق بين الولايات المتحده
وايران بشان برنامج طهران النووي اوضحت
الصحيفه نقلا عن مسؤولين اسرائيليين ان
عدم دعوه رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي الى
الولايات المتحده يرجع بالاساس الى عدم
رغبه واشنطن في اي عرقل ذلك مساعيها في
التوصل لاتفاق مع ايران وترغب طهران في
العوده الى اتفاق 2015 وهو ما تعارضه
واشنطن التي عقدت اتفاقا مؤقتا يشمل صفقه
لتبادل الاسرى والافراج عن الاصول
الايرانيه المجمده
تل ابيب لا تزالوا تاملوا في اجهاض اي
اتفاق محتمل بين الولايات المتحده وايران
وبحثا عن فني واشنطن عن مواصله محادثاتها
مع طهران سيجتمع وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
مع وزير الدفاع الامريكي في بلد اوروبي لم
يتم تحديده حتى الان كما ان تل ابيب بعثت
برساله صارمه الى واشنطن تحذر فيها من
امكانيه استغلال طهران للاتفاق النووي
كغطاء لمواصله مساعيها في الحصول على
الاسلحه النوويه هذا وصرح نتنياهو بان اي
تسويه مع ايران لن تكون ملزمه لاسرائيل
مضيفا ان تل ابيب ستعمل ما يلزم لحمايه
نفسها سواء كان هناك اتفاق مع ايران ام لا
يوم الخميس الماضي تحدثت مع وزير الخارجيه
الاميركي
واكدت على موقفنا الثابت العوده الى
الاتفاق النووي مع ايران لن توقف برنامج
الطيران النووي بل ستسمح لايران فقط
بتوجيه الاموال بمبالغ كبيره الى اذرعها
في المنطقه وحول حدود اسرائيل شددت على ان
اي اتفاق مع ايران لن يلزم اسرائيل مع او
بدون اتفاق سنواصل القيام بكل ما هو ضروري
لحمايه اراضينا
طهران من جهتها مشاهدينا لم تنفي وجود
توافق مع الغرب الى انها رفضت فرض اي
املاءات او قيود عليها بخصوص امكانيه
صنعها لاسلحه النوويه هذا ما جاء على لسان
المرشد الايراني علي خامنئي الذي قال انه
ليس بمقدور اي كان منع ايران من صنع اسلحه
نوويه اذا ارادت ذلك هذا واوضح في الوقت
نفسه ان ايران لا تريد صنع اسلحه نوويه
بسبب عقيدتها الدينيه على حد قوله وليس
لسبب اخر كما اقر بانه من الممكن فعلا ان
تتوصل ايران الى اتفاق مع الغرب شريطه عدم
المساس بالبنيه التحتيه النوويه لايران
يجب عدم المساس بالبنيه التحتيه للصناعه
النوويه خلال هذه السنوات قام المديرون
والمسؤولون والناشطون في هذه الصناعه
باعمال مهمه وانشاوا بنيه تحتيه كبيره قد
ترغبون في عقد اتفاقيات في بعض المجالات
النوويه لا توجد مشكله اتفقوا لكن لا
ينبغي المساس بالبنا التحتيه ولا ينبغي ان
تتضرر يجب احترامها فهذه هي نتائج جهود
الاخرين
اسرائيل تخشى كثيرا مما تصفه بالتهديد
الايراني وهذا ما يدفعها لبذل قصار جهودها
للتحضير لكل السيناريوهات الممكنه بهذا
الخصوص كشفت صحيفه يدعوت احرنوت دائما عن
بدء الجيش الاسرائيلي بالاستعداد مؤخرا
لاحتمال احتمال حقيقي لنشوب حرب مع ايران
وتعمل شعبه الاستخبارات في الجيش
الاسرائيلي على استكمال تحضيراتها للحرب
الاسرائيليه الايرانيه الاولى على حد قول
يدعو تحرنت
كبيرا في استراتيجيه اسرائيل لمواجهه
ما قصراني الاكثر من ذلك
فشا الفرع 54 وهو وحده مخصصه لمواجهه
ايران وتم انشاؤها في قسم الابحاث في شعبه
الاستخبارات الفرع 54 يركز على دراسه
الحرس الثوري استخباراتيا فضلا عن حزب
الله وحركه حماس ايضا ويضم الفرع الجديد
30 جنديا جلهم من كبار الضباط
الاسرائيليين يشتغلون بتنسيق مع خبراء
امريكيين
[موسيقى]
خطه اسرائيل الجديده تاتي كنتيجه للقلق
الاسرائيلي المتزايد من التحركات
الايرانيه الاخيره فايران عززت قواتها
العسكريه بشكل واضح كما ان العلاقات
الاستراتيجيه والعسكريه مع روسيا والصين
عرفت تطورا واضحا يضاف الى ذلك امكانيه
ابرام اتفاق النووي مع ايران ما يعني
تخفيف العقوبات المفروضه عليها وبالتالي
منحها قوه اضافيه
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات